- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked large-brained. Long the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Philip] We've heard a lot at this point
about the evolution of hominids in Africa.
It's a complicated history for sure. Let
me at this point just cut to the chase and
say that humans moved out of Africa
probably just after 2 million years ago
and it will be that part of the record
that I want to emphasize this afternoon.
The site of Dmanisi in the Georgian
Caucasus is very important, records the
oldest known, at this point, the oldest
known occupations of Eurasia beginning
before 1.85 million years ago. We don't
actually have human remains that are that
old, but certainly there are stone tools
approaching that date. The good part about
Dmanisi is that in fact we have not just
scraps of headlamp and bumper and so
forth, but virtually whole skeletons and a
number of them. Now we have five skulls in
various states of repair or disrepair.
Along with them, there are post cranial
bones associated with one juvenile
individual particularly perhaps but not
clearly associated with one of the adults.
Also the material is extremely
well-preserved. We're very fortunate in
that respect. Along with the humans, of
course there are animal bones and many,
many of them and there is a very complete
lithic record to go along with this
material which is well-preserved, as I
say, in a very carefully studied
stratigraphic context. Several of the
specimens from Dmanisi have been in the
past likened to African Homo erectus but
the skeletons are quite primitive. One of
them in particular is strikingly so, Skull
5 which I will talk about. At the moment,
I think it's fair to say that the
taxidermic identity and the
paleobiological significance of the
Dmanisi materials remain controversial.
Certainly there have been plenty of
suggestions and I'm afraid I've been
responsible for some of them but we'll see
where things go. Dmanisi is situated in
Georgia. Georgia is stuck there between
the Black Sea and the Caspian with
Azerbaijan off to the east. From Tbilisi,
the capital, it's about an hour and a
half, an hour and 45 minutes ride. Roads
are pretty good these days. Roads were
terrible 15 years ago. Things have
improved. Down to the site, Dmanisi is
just a few kilometers from the Armenian
border. This is the obligatory excavations
in progress slide. There are about four
meters of sedimentary deposits at Dmanisi.
Much of this stuff is volcanic in origin,
it's very ashy. There are some other
sediments and silts, but ash is always a
primary component which is a good thing.
The stratigraphy is complex, all of the
sediments are piled atop the Mashavera
basalt which is about 1.85 million years
old, that's the bottom of the site, the
earliest record, 1.85 million years is the
date obtained from radiometric
methodology. It is secure. The
stratigraphy at the site is complex
partially because there are a number of
piping features. Water was present near
the site during periods of heavy rain and
so on. Pipes formed underground and then
progressed through breaching to collapse
towards the surface filled with sediments
then got buried again. So it's been a
mess, it's been very hard to sort it out.
Our geologist, Reid Ferring, has done a
huge amount of work in this respect, huge
in the Trumpian sense. But there have been
problems. The first traces of human
material were found at Dmanisi in 1991.
Excavations in fact have been underway at
the site for quite a period of time before
that. The site is underneath an old
medieval town that was on the Silk Road.
The archeologists were busy at Dmanisi for
some time poking around the foundations of
the old buildings and eventually they
began to dig up stuff that didn't seem to
belong there, not just the goats and fish
bones from medieval suppers, but things
that looked quite antique indeed. The
paleontologists came in and ascertain that
yes, the material was ancient, deeper
excavations got underway and in 1991, the
folks at Dmanisis were rewarded with this
jaw, the D211 mandible. It's remarkably
complete, not all of it is there. But what
there is remarkably well-preserved. It's a
small jaw and in a number of respects, it
does look like Homo erectus. You've seen
one reference to this specimen already.
The teeth are about right for Homo erectus
as are the proportions of the mandible
itself. The cranium which turns out to be
the match to the little mandible was found
later in 1999, D2282 is a small cranium,
very small capacity, surprisingly so for
Homo erectus. Only a bit more than 650 CCs
in this case. Despite the small brain, the
thing does share a number of
characteristics with particularly early
African erectus. This hulk turned up at
the site in 2005. It's way down at the
bottom of the site and within a few days
after the fossil had been uncovered and
cleaning was underway prior to trying to
lift it out, there was a very heavy rain.
Things were very nearly washed out. Of
course we have a cover over the site,
there is protection, but it rained so much
and so long that water began to trickle in
around the sides of the excavations and
things were dicey for a while.
Fortunately, D4500 survived. There it is
all cleaned up. It turns out that the
cranium found in 2005 is a perfect match,
once again, to a mandible, D2600, which
had been found earlier in the year 2000.
The upper and the lower, the cranium and
the mandible simply clicked together once
the stuff have been cleaned off, there was
no doubt at all. There is some pathology
on the mandible that matches, comparable
pathology in the region of the ear of the
cranium so there is no doubt about the
match. More than other Dmanisi hominins,
Skull 5, as this one is known, exhibits
very robust morphology. It's pretty
clearly a male individual. Determining sex
in the case of these fossil hominins is
often tricky, often can't be done very
accurately. But in this case, we think we
have a match, the skull says male all
over. Such a pattern given the fact that
it has the smallest brain of all the
Dmanisi hominins because it is unexpected.
Normally for other primates, humans too of
course, but for primates, higher primates
generally, males tend to exceed the
females in brain size by something like 8
to 10 to 15%. So, having the tiniest brain
attached to the most robust cranium and
jaw is a bit surprising. You can see that
there is a good deal of variation within
the Dmanisi assemblage. The little jaw
goes with a smallish brain case which is
quite gracile in its construction. We peg
that one Skull 2 as likely a female. Skull
5, on the other hand is much more robust,
clearly distinctive in a number of
respects. Number 1 is like Homo erectus,
number 4 is a small individual. That one
seems to have lived to a ripe old age
since it had lost almost its entire
dentition, maybe one tooth was still in
place at the time the individual died.
That one may or may not be male, we're not
sure. Anyway, there is a great deal of
diversity at Dmanisi. The crania do look
different. This raises the question of
"How many species might be documented at
the site?" This is a question that's been
plaguing us for some time. I think myself
on the basis of the shared anatomy among
the Dmanisi individuals, they have a
common bow plan extending not just to the
cranial vault but to the face insofar as
we have it represented. And also to the
details of the cranial base suggest, the
common bow plan suggests that all of the
individuals are drawn from just one group.
We've done extensive resampling analysis
as well which cause us to come to the same
conclusion that really, in fact, the
skulls, the post-cranial remains that go
with them, are drawn from just one
population. Now there is stratigraphic
evidence relating to this question. It
doesn't solve the question of course, but
it's important information. It's good to
know that the material was all washed into
these deposits or arrived in the site by
one means or another at about the same
time that is the duration here can't be
more than a few hundred or perhaps a
thousand years or so according to the best
analyses conducted by the geological side
of the team. We'll say, then, that it's
very likely that the Dmanisi assemblage
samples a population belonging to a single
species. I know there may be objections to
this. I'm sure there will be, there have
been in the past. If it's true, then such
a situation is quite rare. Of course, at
most localities where hominins are
discovered, you've heard a lot about East
Africa at this point, Koobi Fora, Olduvai.
Also at Sangiran in Java where there are a
number of fossils. The material is
scattered through a very long sequence of
deposits covering a long period in time.
Time as a contributor variation just
cannot be discounted. If the Dmanisi
fossils document what we can call a
population in the past extending over
quite a number of years of course, then
the next question, the next important
question is how the Dmanisi sample may
relate to the hominin taxa that have
previously been recognized. Skill 5 of
course has a very small brain case, a very
large projecting face in the vault. Also
in the basal cranium, there are some
resemblances, not a lot, but some
resemblances to Homo erectus. Skull 3
which I have not shown you a picture of
before is the sub-adult from Dmanisi.
Skull 3 is pictured here down below. Skull
3 is similar to Homo habilis. This is true
for the bow ridge, the extended brow ridge
development. It's true particularly for
the shape of the vault, the rounding at
the back and for the mid-facial profile.
Skull 3, I must point out, is sub-adult so
we must allow for some extra growth to
have occurred if the individual had grown
up. It might have looked, had it grown up,
a bit more robust and a bit like the skull
to the left there, Homo habilis KNM-ER
1813. Skulls 2 and 4 also have their
peculiar aspects, of course. They have a
number of primitive characters that they
also share some features with Homo
habilis. So, which species? There is, as
I've pointed out, much variation within
the Dmanisi paleodeme. This is not an easy
question, the question as to which species
may be represented. Skull 5, the very
small brained and very robust and very
primitive looking individual does indeed
share some characters with
Australopithecus as well as Homo. So
perhaps in this case, the line, the
division between Australopithecus on the
one hand and earlier Homo on the other is
not so clear cut after all. Many of these
shared similarities are primitive
characters and unfortunately they don't
help us much in answering key questions
about phylogenetic affinities. Other
characters expressed in the Dmanisi
materials are Homo erectus-like and pretty
clearly they are specialized characters,
characters that have changed during the
course of evolution, characters that are
said to be derived. These characters
include the form of the brow ridge for
example which is larger and bar-like, a
little bit of midline, keeling on the
vault, details of temporal bone
construction, things of that sort on the
underside of the vault. Indeed, when
Skulls 1 and 2 were first described back
in the year 2000, they were grouped with
early Homo erectus from the Turkana basin.
If the fossils are included with Homo
erectus, clearly that's one way to deal
with the material is simply to lump it
with Homo erectus. If that is the course
we take, then it must be recognized that
the boundaries between Homo erectus on the
one hand and other early Homo taxa will
become less distinct. It will be
particularly difficult to distinguish
early Homo erectus, African Homo erectus
from specimens attributed to earlier Homo
to Homo habilis in particular. Homo
habilis is considered apart from Homo
rudolfensis. So, to sum up at this point,
here is again a speciose view of Hominin
phylogeny done by Bernard Wood with Meave
Leakey several years ago. You can read the
caution sign. To sum up then, there is
apparently no simple answer to the
question as to which species may be
represented at our site. Indeed this
question is often a tricky one. It's been
a hard one for paleoanthropologists to
deal with for a long time. In one view,
this view expressed on the slide, Dr. Wood
showed you another version of this very
spaciose hominin phylogeny. In that view
hominin evolution has produced a veritable
flowering of lineages over more than 6
million years. Such bushiness, as it were,
is particular evident for the 2.5 to 1
million year ago interval. This interval
in which Paranthropus on the one hand,
Australopithecus and Homo are represented
by multiple species for each group. At
Dmanisi the fossils seem clearly to be
Homo. Now there are some points of overlap
with Australopithecus as I pointed out,
but I would say unbalanced the evidence
favors grouping all of our fossils with
the genus Homo, very little doubt about
that. At the same time, the assemblage at
Dmanisi does not fall neatly into one of
the taxonomic packages that have been
proposed: Homo habilis, Homo rudolfensis,
Homo ergaster, Homo erectus and so on. If
I were pressed and I do feel pressed at
this point, given the morphological
resemblances of Dmanisi to both Homo
habilis in a very strict sense, just those
fossils allocated to Homo habilis, not to
Homo rudolfensis. Given the resemblances
of our material to Homo habilis, and to
early Homo erectus, particularly African
Homo erectus, I would probably argue, I
will argue, that it is most reasonable to
place all of these fossils within a single
evolutionary species. I would say that the
Dmanisi fossils constitute just one
population within this unbranched lineage.
Now, this is not to raise the specter of
just one species at a time, or to suggest
that there isn't a great deal of diversity
in the hominin record, clearly there was
particularly in that interval after, about
2.5 million years. But as far as our
evidence is concerned, it seems to me the
best way to go, simply to place all the
fossils within one evolutionary species.
Then of course we'd have to argue about
what to call it, but this is not the place
for that. So, with that, thanks for
listening. Thanks very much.
♪ [music] ♪